Katrina:  那就把这个拿了
Katrina: Let's take this then.
Tasha: 算了吧那把这个拿了吧
Tasha: Fine, let's take this.
Katrina:  好谦让哈哈哈
Katrina: So considerate, haha.
Katrina:  还有什么
Katrina: What else?
Tasha: 我们还找
Tasha: We'll keep looking.
Tasha: 我们还买了个芋
Tasha: We also bought some taro.
Tasha: 魔芋魔芋魔芋啊
Tasha: Konjac, konjac, konjac.
你们有买魔芋吗
Did you buy konjac?
Tasha: 你们有买魔芋吗
Tasha: Did you buy konjac?
Lucia: 我们没有吧
Lucia: I don't think so.
Tasha: 那就行那我把豆腐拿走
Tasha: Okay, then I'll take the tofu.
Katrina:  没有那就够了
Katrina: No, that's enough.
Tasha: 唉你好荔浦
Tasha: Hey, hello, Lipu.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 这个店没有了
Tasha: This shop doesn't have it.
Tasha: 别的店可能会有
Tasha: Maybe another shop does.
Tasha: 羊杂店 远吗
Tasha: Is the lamb organ soup shop far?
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: It’s fine.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice: 这还是个公的
Alice: This one is male.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 公的哈哈哈
Lucia: A male, hahaha.
Lucia: 发现盲点
Lucia: Found a blind spot.
Jake:哈哈哈揣俩蛋
Jake: Hahaha, carrying two eggs.
Katrina: 来吧一起
Katrina: Come on, together.
Tasha: 芋头这家店没有了
Tasha: This shop doesn't have taro.
Alice: 荔浦鱼头
Alice: Lipu fish head.
Tasha: 这家店没有
Tasha: This shop doesn't have it.
Tasha: 另一家店有
Tasha: Another shop has it.
Katrina:  有什么
Katrina: What do they have?
Alice: 在哪说
Alice: Where did they say?
Tasha: 说很近
Tasha: He said it's very close.
Tasha: 另外一家很近
Tasha: The other one is very close.
Alice: 他能调货吗
Alice: Can he transfer the goods?
Lucia: 我们刚才找到了保鲜膜
Lucia: We just found the plastic wrap.
Jake:拍拍拍个照拍个照拍个照吧
Jake: Take a picture, take a picture, take a picture.
Tasha: 他调不了
Tasha: He can't transfer it.
Lucia: 他一起吗
Lucia: Is he with us?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 他是真的吗
Tasha: Is he for real?
Alice: 假的
Alice: No, he's fake.
Jake:来拍照了
Jake: Come on, take the picture.
Jake:好放回去
Jake: Okay, put it back.
Tasha: 为什么要跟一只鸡合照
Tasha: Why are we taking a picture with a chicken?
Lucia: 这是顺手的
Lucia: It's convenient.
Katrina:  哈哈因为太辣了
Katrina: Haha, because it's too spicy.
Jake:因为看到了
Jake: Because we saw it.
Alice:这是下蛋公鸡
Alice: This is a laying rooster.
Shure: 下蛋公鸡
Shure: A laying rooster.
Shure: 公鸡下蛋公鸡中的战斗机
Shure: A laying rooster, the fighter jet of roosters.
Lucia: 出现
Lucia: It appeared.
Shure:  行大家的表情一样的僵硬
Shure: Everyone's expressions are equally stiff.
Shure:  我就哈哈哈放心了
Shure: I'm just hahahaha relieved.
Shure:  哈哈哈像
Shure: Hahaha like.
Jake:相对民众
Jake: Compared to the public.
Katrina:  这好像是个动图吧
Katrina: This seems to be a GIF, right?
Katrina:  是动图吧
Katrina: It's a GIF, right?
Katrina:  我跟你讲我们原来那个
Katrina: Let me tell you, our old...
Shure:  是动图我们办公室拍照
Shure: It's a GIF. We took pictures in our office.
Shure:  然后有一个是原来当过idol的那种
Shure: And there was someone who used to be an idol.
Shure:  嗯然后就
Shure: Yeah, and then...
Shure:  他跟我们就感觉不是一个涂层的
Shure: He didn't feel like he was in the same layer as us.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK OK.
Shure:  就人家那个表情管理和装造我靠
Shure: His expression management and styling, wow.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 呃有个音效你去听一下
Tasha: Uh, there's a sound effect, go listen to it.
Lucia: 没有音效是他模仿的
Lucia: There's no sound effect, he was mimicking it.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 你给每个人都看一眼
Tasha: Show it to everyone.
Tasha: 哈哈哈然后我们去买保鲜膜
Tasha: Hahaha, then let's go buy some cling film.
Katrina: 弹舌吗
Katrina: Tongue twister?
Alice:你去学俄语吧
Alice: You should learn Russian.
Tasha: 买个羽绒吧
Tasha: Let's buy a down jacket.
Katrina: 我不会
Katrina: I can't do it.
Tasha: 还有个薄荷
Tasha: And some mint.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 不一定能买的到
Tasha: We might not be able to find it.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 然后就没了
Tasha: That's it.
Shure:  我原来也不会
Shure: I didn't know either.
Shure:  我记得有一天滑个滑板
Shure: I remember one day I was skateboarding.
Tasha:奶粉也不一定
Tasha: Milk powder might not be available either.
Shure:  然后一下就会了
Shure: And I suddenly got it.
Jake:再拍一次管理一下
Jake: Let's shoot it again and manage it.
Jake: 能管理的了吗
Jake: Can you manage it?
Shure:  管理不了
Shure: I can't manage it.
Lucia: 管理一下管理一下
Lucia: Manage it, manage it.
Jake: 管理一下好
Jake: Alright, manage it.
Shure:  怎么怎么管理一下
Shure: How do we manage it?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: I have no idea.
Shure:  就是看着像正常人类一点
Shure: Just try to look more like a normal human.
Katrina: 禁止禁止 10秒钟
Katrina: Stop, stop for 10 seconds.
Jake: 那很难那很难
Jake: That's really hard.
Jake: 这回来个10秒的
Jake: Let's do a 10-second one this time.
Shure:  10秒
Shure: 10 seconds.
Katrina:  10秒他保持不了10秒进去
Katrina: He can't hold for 10 seconds, go in.
Jake: 那就酝酿一会
Jake: Then let's give it a moment.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Jake: 你的音效声音
Jake: Your sound effect.
Lucia: 看大家的管理成果
Lucia: Let's see everyone's management results.
Tasha: 表情管理成果吗
Tasha: You mean expression management results?
Jake: 看一看
Jake: Let's take a look.
Katrina:  可以无所谓
Katrina: Doesn't matter.
Alice: 鸦雀无声
Alice: Silence.
Lucia: 鸦雀无声
Lucia: Silence.
Jake:没事
Jake: It's fine.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Tasha: go
Tasha: Go.
Katrina:  还缺啥吗
Katrina: Do we need anything else?
Tasha: 还缺保鲜膜
Tasha: We're still missing some plastic wrap.
Tasha: 你们买一下
Tasha: Can you guys buy some?
Katrina: 买了
Katrina: Got it.
Lucia: 买了我们买了保鲜膜
Lucia: We bought it, we got the plastic wrap.
Lucia: 保鲜膜买了
Lucia: We bought the plastic wrap.
Lucia: 找到了
Lucia: Found it.
Tasha: 还有什么
Tasha: What else?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Egg tart crust.
Alice:荔浦芋头
Alice: Lipu taro.
Tasha: 芋头没有
Tasha: No taro.
Shure:  杨老板头大了
Shure: Jake's getting a headache.
Alice:没了
Alice: None left.
Tasha: 薄荷买了吗
Tasha: Did you get the mint?
Katrina:  没有买薄荷哎
Katrina: We didn't get the mint.
Alice: 没有薄荷可能
Alice: No mint maybe.
Tasha: 是没有薄荷
Tasha: There's no mint.
Jake:没有这些都很便宜听起来
Jake: All these things sound cheap.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Alright.
Shure:  知道什么叫聚沙成塔
Shure: Do you know what "every little bit counts" means?
Shure:  压死骆驼的最后一根稻草吗
Shure: The last straw that breaks the camel's back?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Egg tart crust.
Katrina: 薄荷蛋挞皮薄荷
Katrina: Mint, egg tart crust, mint.
Jake: 最后一个蛋挞皮
Jake: The last egg tart crust.
Lucia: 最后一个蛋挞皮
Lucia: The last egg tart crust.
Alice: 实在没有薄荷
Alice: There's really no mint.
Alice:要不然下楼摘点叶子吧
Alice: How about we go downstairs and pick some leaves?
Alice: 把我们那花剪点当装饰
Alice: Let's cut some of our flowers for decoration.
Tasha: 没有 nothing
Tasha: There's nothing, nothing.
Alice:你在找啥
Alice: What are you looking for?
Alice: 蛋挞皮
Alice: Egg tart crust.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Alice:这蛋挞
Alice: This egg tart...
Shure:  烘焙区是不是在前面
Shure: Isn't the baking section up ahead?
Tasha: 那吗
Tasha: Over there?
Shure:  好像是吧我刚才看到烘焙俩字
Shure: Seems like it, I just saw the word "baking."
Tasha: 烘焙区是烘口的
Tasha: The baking section is for baking.
Tasha: 对不是这儿
Tasha: Yeah, not here.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Hahaha, no, no.
Lucia: 这些非工作人员请勿触碰
Lucia: These non-staff members, please do not touch.
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
Tasha: 他说烘焙区里面有烘蛋挞
Tasha: He said there's baked egg tarts in the baking area.
Jake:我也不碰了
Jake: I won't touch it either.
Lucia: 小心危险
Lucia: Be careful, it's dangerous.
Katrina: 老北京豆汁
Katrina: Old Beijing Douzhi.
Alice:有熟的
Alice: There's some cooked ones.
Shure:  嚯跟后台要
Shure: Whoa, ask the backstage for it.
Katrina: 拿两盒豆汁
Katrina: Grab two boxes of Douzhi.
Tasha: 啊没有唉
Tasha: Ah, there's none.
Lucia: 但实话说
Lucia: But to be honest,
Lucia: 我也挺好奇
Lucia: I'm also really curious
Lucia: 他们上面那个Logic chain是干嘛用的
Lucia: about what that Logic chain on top is for.
Tasha: 你好我想问有哎蛋挞皮吗蛋挞皮
Tasha: Hello, I want to ask if you have egg tart crusts? Egg tart crusts.
Tasha: 啊超市里没有
Tasha: Ah, the supermarket doesn't have any.
Tasha: 应该在冻柜里吧
Tasha: It should be in the freezer section, right?
Tasha: 好像有蛋挞皮
Tasha: Seems like there's egg tart crusts.
Lucia: 我们诶这个好可爱
Lucia: This one is so cute.
Tasha: 那蛋挞液在哪里啊
Tasha: Then where's the egg tart filling?
Tasha: 这都没有呀 啊
Tasha: There's nothing here, ah.
Tasha: 服务台在那吗 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Is the service desk over there? Egg tart crusts.
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Tasha: 尊嘟好过分呀
Tasha: Respectfully, that's too much.
Tasha: 在吃伞底下就应该喝椰子
Tasha: You should drink coconut under the umbrella.
Alice:蛋挞皮能用啥替代呢
Alice: What can we use to substitute the egg tart crust?
Tasha: 没有东西能替代
Tasha: Nothing can substitute it.
Alice: 馄饨皮
Alice: Wonton wrappers.
Alice: 馄饨皮刷蛋液行吗
Alice: Can we brush egg wash on wonton wrappers?
Tasha: 超市有蛋挞皮吗蛋挞皮
Tasha: Does the supermarket have egg tart crusts? Egg tart crusts.
Tasha: 嗯蛋挞液和蛋挞皮
Tasha: Hmm, egg tart filling and egg tart crusts.
Jake:哎呦我去哈哈哈
Jake: Oh my gosh, hahaha.
Tasha: 有吗咦
Tasha: Is there any? Huh?
Tasha: 是什么牌子
Tasha: What brand is it?
Alice:没有
Alice: There's none.
Tasha: 好吧谢谢谢谢谢谢
Tasha: Alright, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Tasha: 啊没有那就只
Tasha: Ah, there's none, then we'll just
Tasha: 能在网上买了
Tasha: have to buy it online.
Tasha: 你看就是今天可以免费领的区
Tasha: Look, this is the area where you can get things for free today.
Alice:有我们要的吗
Alice: Do they have what we want?
Alice:嗯这是大馒头
Alice: Hmm, this is a big bun.
Tasha: 是的蓝莓
Tasha: Yes, blueberry.
Alice:吃火锅需要面吗
Alice: Do we need noodles for hot pot?
Tasha: 呃你有会员吗
Tasha: Uh, do you have a membership?
Tasha: 要x会员
Tasha: You need an X membership.
Alice:x会员好像不是吧
Alice: X membership? I don't think so.
Tasha: 黄金会员钻石会员的主卡
Tasha: The main card for Gold or Diamond membership.
Tasha: 普通会员拉倒
Tasha: Ordinary membership doesn't count.
Tasha: 不行
Tasha: No way.
Tasha: 要298一年
Tasha: It costs 298 per year.
Tasha: 不然我天天都领
Tasha: Otherwise, I'd collect it every day.
Tasha: 米狗套没有
Tasha: There's no set with rice dogs.
Tasha: 问过服务台了
Tasha: I asked at the service desk.
Katrina:  薄荷和那个什么芋泥
Katrina: Mint and that taro thing.
Katrina:  还有那个蛋挞皮都没有
Katrina: And the tart crusts are all gone.
Alice: 对别的都可以
Alice: Yes, everything else is fine.
Tasha: 但是蛋挞液自己做的话
Tasha: But if you make the tart filling yourself,
Tasha: 要旺仔牛奶就行了
Tasha: You'll just need Wangzai Milk.
Lucia: 啊我知道了
Lucia: Oh, I got it.
Lucia: 这个是用来送打包外卖的
Lucia: This is for takeout delivery.
Lucia: 刚才看到一个袋子过去
Lucia: I just saw a bag go by.
Lucia: 我终于知道它是干什么的了
Lucia: I finally know what it's for.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  自己做麻烦吗
Katrina: Is it troublesome to make it yourself?
Tasha: 不麻烦
Tasha: Not at all.
Jake:他就是他
Jake: He is who he is.
Jake:走几步很难吗
Jake: Is it that hard to take a few steps?
Alice: 要放淡奶油吧
Alice: Do you need to add cream?
Lucia: 可能是
Lucia: Maybe.
Tasha: 对淡奶油炼乳白砂糖蛋液
Tasha: Yes, cream, condensed milk, white sugar, egg mixture.
Lucia: 给大家造成一种高科技的错觉
Lucia: Gives everyone the illusion of high-tech.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 蛋蛋液就行了
Tasha: The egg mixture is fine.
Tasha: 还有旺仔牛奶
Tasha: And Wangzai Milk.
Alice: 蛋挞皮的话那个
Alice: For the tart crust, um...
Lucia: 但实际上这玩意很像蒸汽朋克时代那种话筒
Lucia: But this thing actually looks like a steampunk-era microphone.
Alice:蛋挞皮能自己做吗蛋挞皮是不是得
Alice: Can you make the tart crust yourself? Isn't the tart crust...
Tasha: 不能
Tasha: No.
Lucia: 可以外送了
Lucia: It can be delivered.
Alice: 对闪溢的
Alice: Right, for Shanyi.
Tasha: 是的但是我想要
Tasha: Yes, but I want...
Tasha: 叫什么奥昆
Tasha: What's it called, Okun?
Tasha: 奥昆
Tasha: Okun
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Tasha: 呃精品
Tasha: Uh, premium.
Jake:草履虫
Jake: Paramecium.
Lucia: 我就是这么以为的
Lucia: That's what I thought.
Katrina: 就是你对牌子有要求吗
Katrina: Do you have any brand preferences?
Jake: 嗯大细菌
Jake: Hmm, large bacteria.
Tasha: 嗯蛋挞皮
Tasha: Hmm, egg tart crust.
Jake: 大肠杆菌
Jake: E. coli.
Shure:  对大肠杆菌
Shure: Yeah, E. coli.
Shure:  大肠杆菌
Shure: E. coli.
Katrina: 你那指甲还挺好看的
Katrina: Your nails look pretty good.
Lucia: 撒了那种
Lucia: Sprinkled with that kind...
Lucia: 就是生日蛋糕上面那种小糖碎的草莓
Lucia: Like those little candy bits on birthday cakes with strawberries.
Katrina: 是裸色吗
Katrina: Is it nude color?
Tasha: 刚掉了 爬墙
Tasha: It just fell off. Climbing the wall.
Katrina: 我我我特想抠
Katrina: I really want to pick at it.
Jake:啊这甜甜圈
Jake: Ah, this donut.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know what?
Jake:吃了一口
Jake: Took a bite.
Katrina: 如果我镶钻了
Katrina: If I had diamonds on it...
Tasha: 我也是我我刚做的
Tasha: Me too, I just got it done.
Shure:  这后面是一个姜饼人
Shure: There's a gingerbread man behind.
Shure:  所以就是没有
Shure: So, there's none.
Alice:没有只能外卖买了吧
Alice: We can only buy it for takeout then.
Jake:是一个
Jake: It's a...
Shure:  只能外卖买了
Shure: We can only buy it for takeout.
Jake: 猫头鹰啊
Jake: An owl?
Lucia: 姜饼
Lucia: Gingerbread.
Jake:姜饼人
Jake: Gingerbread man.
Tasha: 我们买个旺仔牛奶就走吧
Tasha: Let's buy a Wang Zai milk and go.
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where is it?
Jake:姜饼猫头鹰怎么了
Jake: What's with the gingerbread owl?
Katrina:  旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Wang Zai milk.
Tasha: 旺仔牛奶
Tasha: Wang Zai milk.
Tasha: 走,go
Tasha: Go, go.
Tasha: 然后就没了
Tasha: And then that's it.
Jake: 好在哪里
Jake: Where is it?
Tasha: 在哪里牛奶区吧
Tasha: In the milk section, I guess.
Tasha: 他们家不一定有旺仔牛奶
Tasha: They might not have Wang Zai milk here.
Katrina: 人 类是这样的
Katrina: Humans are like this.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Alice: 因为他们家有自自营的那种牛奶
Alice: Because their family runs their own milk business.
Tasha: 算了吧 那就走吧
Tasha: Forget it, let's go.
Lucia: 算了吧那就走吧没有
Lucia: Forget it, let's go, no.
Katrina:  也没有吗
Katrina: They don't have it either?
Katrina:  没有就不一样了
Katrina: If they don't have it, it's different.
Alice:对就不一定有旺仔的
Alice: Yeah, they might not have Want Want milk.
Katrina:  是不是跟他们有品牌竞争啊
Katrina: Are they competing with the brand?
Katrina: 利益冲突
Katrina: Conflict of interest.
Tasha: 因为他们有那个自营的
Tasha: Because they have their own products.
Katrina: 自营嘛对
Katrina: Their own products, right.
Lucia: 所以盒马对标当然是
Lucia: So Hema's target is definitely...
Katrina: 全员竞品啊
Katrina: Competing with everyone.
Katrina: 汇源果汁也没有
Katrina: They don't even have Huiyuan juice.
Tasha: 你你是因为镜头在录所以搞出节目效果是吗
Tasha: Are you doing this for the camera effect?
Katrina: 桃汁也没有
Katrina: They don't even have peach juice.
Jake:没有那你为什么要打我
Jake: If they don't have it, why did you hit me?
Shure: 那种山姆吧我感觉
Shure: It's like Sam's Club, I think.
Katrina: 自营为什么不出桃汁呢
Katrina: Why don't they have their own peach juice?
Jake:为了把你丢这个钻石丢在我的身上啊
Jake: To make you throw this diamond at me.
Lucia: 如果自营有同品类的话会形成竞争而且这样他们可以降低成本
Lucia: If they have their own products, they can reduce costs through competition.
Jake:就是你打我然后丢了钻石
Jake: So you hit me and then lost the diamond.
Tasha: 这里有汉堡胚要不要做汉堡
Tasha: There are burger buns here, do you want to make burgers?
Shure:  好像现在那个美团也在搞
Shure: It looks like Meituan is doing it too now.
Jake:真的可以做哎
Jake: We can really make them.
Tasha: 可以多要做汉堡
Tasha: We can make more burgers.
Tasha: 芝士芝士芝士皮
Tasha: Cheese, cheese, cheese slices.
Tasha: 生菜和番茄 洋葱就行了
Tasha: Lettuce, tomatoes, onions, and that's it.
Jake:好哇
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 尊嘟
Tasha: Zundoo.
Jake:听起来也还行吧
Jake: Sounds good, right?
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 人呢
Tasha: Where's everyone?
Tasha: 你真的要做吗
Tasha: Are you really going to make them?
Jake:可以做
Jake: We can make them.
Tasha: 不要可以做你想吃吗
Tasha: No, can we make them? Do you want to eat them?
Jake:那就做呗
Jake: Then let's make them.
Jake:吃
Jake: Eat.
Tasha: 算了KFC可以买
Tasha: Forget it, we can buy from KFC.
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake: 好啊好啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 在哪里啊
Jake: Where to?
Jake: 结账去了应该
Jake: Going to check out, I guess.
Jake: 收银区去了
Jake: Heading to the checkout area.
Tasha: 你想要我帮你打个折吗
Tasha: Do you want me to get you a discount?
Jake: 怎么折啊
Jake: How would you get a discount?
Tasha: 怎么折
Tasha: How?
Jake: 你有盒马的折吗
Jake: Do you have a Hema discount?
Jake:还是什么意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Tasha: 借的会员
Tasha: Borrowed membership.
Jake: 借的会员
Jake: Borrowed membership?
Tasha: 那肯定要借嘛
Tasha: Of course we need to borrow it.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Yeah?
Shure:  到您了
Shure: It's your turn.
Jake: 到已经扫完了
Jake: Oh, it's done scanning.
Shure:  没有得先扫会员码
Shure: No, you have to scan the membership code first.
Jake: 哦那我也没有啊
Jake: Oh, but I don't have one.
Alice: 普通会员不就行了吗
Alice: Can't we just use a regular membership?
Shure:  不是就必须
Shure: No, it has to be...
Katrina: 你们谁有会员
Katrina: Does anyone have a membership?
Alice:普通会员就可以了
Alice: Regular membership will do.
Tasha: 找88会员
Tasha: Find an 88 membership.
Shure:  我来吧
Shure: I'll do it.
Tasha: 行吧
Tasha: Alright.
Katrina:  88VIP有盒马吗
Katrina: Does 88VIP include Hema?
Tasha: 找88会呃不是88折盒马哦
Tasha: It's 88 membership, not 88 discount for Hema.
Jake: 哦所以你有是吧
Jake: Oh, so you have it?
Tasha: 呃我我呃等一下
Tasha: Uh, let me check.
Jake: 修硕有还是
Jake: Shure has it or?
Lucia: 我甚至没有盒马APP
Lucia: I don't even have the Hema app.
Shure:  我有盒马APP
Shure: I have the Hema app.
Jake:我也我也没有我也没有
Jake: I don't, I don't have it either.
Shure:  但我好像卡里没有那么多钱
Shure: But I don't think I have enough money in my account.
Tasha: 对我我还有优惠券
Tasha: I have coupons.
Alice: 你点不到啊
Alice: You can't click on it?
Lucia: 盒马是必须要用APP才能结账的
Lucia: You have to use the app to check out at Hema.
Lucia: 我刚回国的时候跟我爸逛了一趟
Lucia: When I first got back to China, I went shopping with my dad.
Lucia: 发现只能用APP结账
Lucia: And we found out you can only check out using the app.
Lucia: 我就出去了什么也没买
Lucia: I went out and didn't buy anything.
Jake:哈哈哈那你要坐两个拖车的话
Jake: Hahaha, then if you need two trailers...
Tasha: 算了
Tasha: Never mind.
Jake: 然后怎么放回去
Jake: How do you put it back?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 就是因为那天拿的东西其实也不太行
Lucia: Because the stuff I got that day wasn't great.
Jake:打的东西还行
Jake: What you got was fine.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Alice:哎为什么用不了呢
Alice: Hey, why can't we use it?
Tasha: 稍等
Tasha: Hold on.
Shure: 杨老板要不给给你弄一个
Shure: Jake, do you want me to get you one?
Shure:  好啊支付宝有吧
Shure: Sure, Alipay works, right?
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 支付宝有啊
Jake: Alipay works.
Shure:  那支付宝也行
Shure: Then Alipay is fine.
Shure:  支付宝里有二维码
Shure: There's a QR code in Alipay.
Jake: 支付宝还是有
Jake: Alipay still works.
Alice: 我打开APP
Alice: I'll open the app.
Alice: 不知道为什么点不了二维码
Alice: Not sure why I can't click the QR code.
Alice: 是不是因为我们开着那个啥的
Alice: Is it because we have that thing on?
Alice: 哦但你一关那个啥不就停那啥了吗
Alice: Oh, but if you turn it off, won't it stop that thing?
Alice:把我家地址录上了没关系吧
Alice: It's okay if I recorded my home address, right?
Lucia: 他们会处理好像
Lucia: They will handle it, it seems.
Tasha: 有有有有
Tasha: There is, there is.
Jake:对回头会看一眼
Jake: Yeah, we'll take a look later.
Jake: 那个看一眼这谁的手机
Jake: Whose phone is that?
Katrina: 这谁的手机他的吗
Katrina: Whose phone is that? His?
Jake: 这个压力还是挺大的
Jake: This is quite stressful.
Jake: 把你们的片都看一遍
Jake: Watching all your clips.
Tasha: 还有减20块钱
Tasha: And there's a 20 yuan discount.
Lucia: 我加油
Lucia: I'll give it a try.
Katrina: 你用试试
Katrina: You try it.
Shure: 减20块钱
Shure: 20 yuan discount.
Alice:不过没关系
Alice: But it's okay.
Lucia: 因为我觉得我看手机的时候
Lucia: Because I think when I look at my phone...
Katrina: 这样也可以啊
Katrina: That works too.
Lucia: 肯定会看到我家地址
Lucia: I'll definitely see my home address.
Lucia: 或者之类的类似的东西
Lucia: Or something similar.
Tasha: 我一打开APP就默认我家地址
Tasha: When I open the app, it defaults to my home address.
Tasha: 减20吗
Tasha: 20 yuan off?
Katrina: 不是你有会员吗
Katrina: Don't you have a membership?
Lucia: 我也是
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia: 我今天打开淘宝查材料包的时候也是
Lucia: When I opened Taobao to check the material pack today, same here.
Katrina:  也就用你的呗
Katrina: Just use yours then.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina:  用你的然后让他给你报呗
Katrina: Use yours and then have him reimburse you.
Lucia: 辛苦了哈哈
Lucia: Thanks, haha.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha: hello
Tasha: Hello.
Katrina:  来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Alice: 开始
Alice: Start.
Jake: 发生了什么
Jake: What happened?
Shure:  没事可以开始了
Shure: It's fine, we can start.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 我们要不要再拿一个车过来
Lucia: Should we get another cart?
Tasha: 还亮吗
Tasha: Is it still on?
Shure:  再拿一个道吧
Shure: Get another lane.
Jake: 插个电吧
Jake: Plug it in.
Tasha: 亮那就行
Tasha: If it's on, that's fine.
Alice: 我也是吧
Alice: Me too, I guess.
Alice: 我能看到
Alice: I can see it.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Alright.
Jake:咱咱眼睛插个电吧
Jake: Let's plug it into our eyes.
Jake:别别最后挂掉了
Jake: No, no, it might break.
Jake: 你的电还在吗
Jake: Is your battery still on?
Jake:还有挺好挺好
Jake: Still on, good, good.
Alice:我的电还在
Alice: My battery is still on.
Jake: 我们这些东西怎么带走啊
Jake: How are we going to carry all this stuff?
Tasha: 袋子
Tasha: Bags.
Tasha: 袋子装
Tasha: Put them in bags.
Jake:袋子哦
Jake: Bags, okay.
Lucia: 有种给自己脑子接口一样的感觉
Lucia: It feels like connecting my brain to an interface.
Shure: 先扫俩袋子然后边扫边装
Shure: First grab a couple of bags, then keep grabbing and filling.
Tasha: 就跟自己是个AI机器人给自己充电
Tasha: It's like being an AI robot charging itself.
Katrina: 在哪扫袋子
Katrina: Where to grab the bags?
Jake:给充电对对对电没了
Jake: Charging, right, right, no power left.
Tasha: 你怎么可以
Tasha: How could you?
Alice:放你包里吗先
Alice: Put it in your bag first?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Sure.
Jake: 我可熟练了
Jake: I'm pretty skilled at this.
Jake: 没有人比我更熟练
Jake: No one is more skilled than me.
Lucia: 哇我去看一下
Lucia: Wow, let me go check it out.
Jake:我来帮您来
Jake: Let me help you with that.
Tasha: 好谢谢你
Tasha: Okay, thank you.
Jake:我觉得自己这确实有点难
Jake: I think this is actually a bit difficult.
Jake:多少拿着点啊
Jake: Hold on to it a bit.
Jake: 挺好这个袋子
Jake: This bag is pretty good.
Jake:疼吗
Jake: Does it hurt?
Lucia: 我们那边自助结账的话也是在这拿吗
Lucia: Do we also take it here for self-checkout?
Jake:好行
Jake: Alright, sure.
Tasha: 不疼好了吗
Tasha: It doesn't hurt, is it done?
Jake:好了
Jake: It's done.
Lucia: 大袋大袋
Lucia: Big bag, big bag.
Jake:好了好了
Jake: Done, done.
Lucia: 呃再来一个吧东西有点多
Lucia: Uh, let's get another one, there's a lot of stuff.
Tasha: 买二得三
Tasha: Buy two, get three.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 好哎好了
Tasha: Okay, done.
Jake:好了啊
Jake: All done.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Done.
Jake:可以
Jake: Perfect.
Tasha: 就跟打针一样
Tasha: Just like getting a shot.
Jake:哈哈哈他妈他妈
Jake: Hahaha, mother, mother.
Jake: 好了哈哈
Jake: Done, haha.
Lucia: 怎么感觉好像两个袋也不够
Lucia: How come it feels like two bags aren't enough?
Tasha: 可以先结账
Tasha: We can check out first.
Tasha: 这个已经优惠10块钱了
Tasha: This already has a 10 yuan discount.
Katrina:  先结一部分是吗
Katrina: Check out part of it first, right?
Tasha: 对然后再扫
Tasha: Yes, then scan again.
Tasha: 然后还有两张券
Tasha: And then there are two more coupons.
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Okay, okay.
Jake: 他是什么
Jake: What's that?
Jake: 每100每500省10块
Jake: Save 10 yuan for every 100, 500 spent.
Tasha: 不是我的红包券好不好
Tasha: No, my red envelope coupon, alright?
Tasha: 我在牺牲我自己
Tasha: I'm sacrificing myself here.
Jake:哦哦可以感感谢老板捐10块钱
Jake: Oh, oh, thank you for donating 10 yuan, boss.
Katrina: 那就先付吧
Katrina: Then let's pay first.
Jake: 好这是10块钱捐赠是吧
Jake: Okay, this is the 10 yuan donation, right?
Jake: 哎这些扫没扫呢
Jake: Hey, did you scan these?
Shure:  哎怎么扫
Shure: Hey, how to scan?
Jake:应该怎么扫阿里pay吗
Jake: How do I scan with Alipay?
Lucia: 都是扫过的呢
Lucia: Everything's already scanned.
Shure:  都是扫过的
Shure: Everything's scanned.
Tasha: 请将盒马APP付款码 好吧
Tasha: Please use the Hema app payment code, alright.
Lucia: 这个车里的车还没扫呢
Lucia: The items in this cart haven’t been scanned yet.
Lucia: 那这呃这俩袋子也不够好像
Lucia: And these two bags don’t seem to be enough.
Lucia: 系一下别混一块了
Lucia: Tie them up so they don’t get mixed up.
Katrina:  行吧再再要一个袋子是吧
Katrina: Alright, let's get another bag then.
Alice:心痛
Alice: It hurts my heart.
Tasha: 真的能付成功吗可以吧
Tasha: Can we really complete the payment? We should be able to.
Tasha: 哦可以的
Tasha: Oh, it works.
Katrina:  我们怎么提回去
Katrina: How are we going to carry this back?
Katrina: 打车就在楼下
Katrina: Let's get a taxi, it’s just downstairs.
Jake:100刀100新币
Jake: 100 dollars, 100 Singapore dollars.
Shure:  100新币对
Shure: 100 Singapore dollars, right.
Jake:一车就100新币
Jake: One cart costs 100 Singapore dollars.
Shure:  不到100新币
Shure: Less than 100 Singapore dollars.
Jake: 我每次一塑料袋100新币
Jake: Every time, one plastic bag is 100 Singapore dollars.
Shure:  杨老板就是大气
Shure: Jake is so generous.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Jake: 那可能是400金币
Jake: So it might be 400 gold coins.
Jake: 我估计
Jake: I guess.
Tasha: 这个结过账的
Tasha: This one's already paid for.
Lucia: 对这这里也都结了
Lucia: Yes, everything here is paid for too.
Lucia: 这里这里好像还没结吧
Lucia: This part doesn’t seem to be paid for yet.
Katrina:  放台上没有
Katrina: Put it on the counter, did we?
Katrina:  没有放台上
Katrina: We didn’t put it on the counter.
Alice:这怎么放呢
Alice: How do we put this?
Lucia: 先把这的都挪到这
Lucia: Move everything here first.
Jake:再来一个车
Jake: Get another cart.
Jake: 我再来一辆车
Jake: I’ll get another cart.
Jake: 再来一辆车
Jake: Another cart.
Jake:不用用了哦OK好嘞
Jake: No need, oh OK, got it.
Lucia: 就把这个都挪过来然后
Lucia: Just move all of this over, and then...
Lucia: 那边装完的放到这个车里
Lucia: Put the packed ones into this cart.
Tasha: 他说什么
Tasha: What did he say?
Katrina: 就是没结是吗
Katrina: So it’s not paid for, right?
Jake:结账要先下载好盒马APP才能结账
Jake: To pay, you need to download the Hema app first.
Katrina: 那就交换一下
Katrina: Then let’s swap it.
Katrina: 在那边装袋吧
Katrina: Let’s pack it over there.
Tasha: 新加坡没有盒马是吗
Tasha: Is there no Hema in Singapore?
Jake: 应该没有
Jake: There shouldn't be.
Jake: 我探索的也不多
Jake: I haven't explored much either.
Jake: 那新加坡那边是什么样的超市
Jake: What kind of supermarkets do they have in Singapore?
Lucia: 就这种天生纤维的这种
Lucia: It's like this natural fiber kind.
Katrina: 呀感觉还需要袋子
Katrina: Yeah, it feels like we still need a bag.
Tasha: 我听说新加坡都说中文
Tasha: I heard they all speak Chinese in Singapore.
Lucia: 全食吗
Lucia: Whole Foods?
Jake:不是就是他们有一家fire price
Jake: No, they have something called Fire Price.
Jake: 应该是政府给了很多补贴的
Jake: It's heavily subsidized by the government.
Jake: 哦叫fire price
Jake: Oh, it's called Fire Price.
Jake: 很便宜对对对
Jake: It's very cheap, yeah.
Lucia: 这个线老是让我弄得很奇怪
Lucia: This wire always makes me feel weird.
Jake:哎我帮你
Jake: Hey, let me help you.
Jake:要不就是这个放你后面
Jake: Or maybe put this behind you.
Shure:  再来一个袋
Shure: Another bag, please.
Shure:  你好你好
Shure: Hello, hello.
Shure:  再来一个袋
Shure: Another bag, please.
Lucia: 有点卷插头
Lucia: The plug is a bit twisted.
Tasha: 都结过账了
Tasha: We've already paid.
Katrina:  对方台上都是结过账
Katrina: Everything on the counter is paid for.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 要不然好像我动着动着
Lucia: Otherwise, it feels like I'm moving and moving...
Lucia: 他就快要把我缠起来了
Lucia: And it starts to wrap around me.
Jake:这个是久经验证的插电姿势
Jake: This is a well-tested way to plug it in.
Jake:对其实在后面绕过来最好后面贴个胶
Jake: Actually, it's best to loop it from the back and tape it.
Lucia: 你是做过多少次这样类似的实验了
Lucia: How many times have you done similar experiments?
Jake: 对这个1月份到的
Jake: Yeah, this arrived in January.
Jake: 我带着这个到处
Jake: I've been carrying it around.
Jake: 就看比赛啊
Jake: Watching competitions and stuff.
Jake: 进城都带着这个东西
Jake: I take this thing everywhere in the city.
Jake: 哦看比赛还可以那
Jake: Oh, it’s good for watching competitions.
Lucia: 那会把比赛整个
Lucia: Can it record and model the whole competition?
Lucia: 记录建模下来吗
Lucia: Like the whole match?
Jake: 这个不会
Jake: No, it can't.
Jake:这个不会这个就版权的问题
Jake: It can't due to copyright issues.
Jake: 只能扫扫进场的仪式
Jake: It can only scan the entry ceremony and stuff.
Tasha: 那
Tasha: So,
Tasha: 那看电影的时候能把电影记下来吗
Tasha: Can it record a movie when you're watching it?
Alice:这个放别的地
Alice: Let's put this somewhere else.
Lucia: 那也不行吧
Lucia: That won't work either.
Lucia: 也牵涉版权哦
Lucia: It's also about copyright.
Lucia: 这不就是枪版
Lucia: Isn't this just a cam version?
Jake: 哈哈哈这就是枪版
Jake: Hahaha, it is a cam version.
Lucia: 3D枪版
Lucia: A 3D cam version.
Jake:这就是枪版
Jake: This is a cam version.
Lucia: 坐在电影院的体验
Lucia: The cinema experience.
Jake: 哎是的是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it is.
Jake:我带一个这个进去给你打出来
Jake: I'll bring this in and make a copy for you.
Alice:放点轻的吧
Alice: Play something lighter.
Jake:哈哈我就这个装备进电影院
Jake: Haha, I'll take this gear into the cinema.
Alice:我觉得这个有点够呛了
Alice: I think this is a bit too much.
Katrina: 放点小饮料吧
Katrina: Play some small drinks.
Lucia: 感觉很酷炫的样子
Lucia: It looks pretty cool.
Alice:这拖着底抱
Alice: This drags on the bottom.
Katrina:  这什么呀
Katrina: What is this?
Jake: 感觉两条腿都要断
Jake: Feels like my legs will break.
Shure:  再去拿两个袋
Shure: Go get two more bags.
小Lucia: 再来两个袋
Little Lucia: Get two more bags.
Jake: 耍赖吗
Jake: Are you cheating?
Jake: 这边有冰块
Jake: There are ice cubes here.
Jake: 保鲜冰块
Jake: Preserving ice cubes.
Jake: 保鲜冰块能吃吗
Jake: Can we eat preserving ice cubes?
Tasha: 呃不能吃
Tasha: Uh, no.
Jake: 好吧好吧好吧
Jake: Alright, alright.
Tasha: 但是你可以带
Tasha: But you can bring them.
Tasha: 呃也不用吧
Tasha: Uh, no need.
Jake: 我们用不着吧
Jake: We don't need them.
Tasha: 我问问
Tasha: I'll ask.
Tasha: 这个冰块可以吃吗
Tasha: Can we eat these ice cubes?
Tasha: 姐啊
Tasha: Sis?
Tasha: 这个不能吃
Tasha: We can't eat these.
Katrina:  要多少钱拿
Katrina: How much do we need to take?
Jake: 编辑一下
Jake: Edit it a bit.
Lucia: 矫正视力
Lucia: Correct the vision.
Katrina: 你那个券是多少
Katrina: How much is the coupon?
Katrina: 满多少
Katrina: How much to get?
Jake: 我们视力都有问题
Jake: We all have vision problems.
Jake: 就是我们6个人一样的问题
Jake: All six of us have the same problem.
Tasha: 有点
Tasha: A bit.
Alice:这个结过了吗
Alice: Has this been tied up?
Jake: 病友
Jake: Fellow patient
Katrina:  都结过了
Katrina: It's all tied up
Tasha: 什么病友
Tasha: What fellow patient?
Jake: 呃对
Jake: Uh, yeah
Jake: 对呃这是全景
Jake: Yes, uh, this is the full view
Tasha: 博主探店的
Tasha: The vlogger is reviewing the shop
Jake: 博主博主
Jake: Vlogger, vlogger
Jake: 对对6人博主
Jake: Yes, yes, 6 people vlogger
Jake: 博主探店
Jake: The vlogger is reviewing the shop
Katrina:  博主能送两个菜吗
Katrina: Can the vlogger give us two dishes?
Jake: 对网上见就是好吧
Jake: Yeah, seeing it online is just fine
Jake: 哈哈哈自己开个超市是吧
Jake: Haha, open your own supermarket, right?
Jake: 自己开个盒马
Jake: Open your own Hema
Lucia: 这个也做美食
Lucia: This one also makes food
Lucia: 哈哈对我们有美食专家
Lucia: Haha, yes we have a food expert
Tasha: 哎等一下别再扫了
Tasha: Hey, wait a minute, don't scan anymore
Tasha: 还还可以用下一个券呢
Tasha: You can still use the next coupon
Alice: 还没到500呢
Alice: It's not up to 500 yet
Tasha: 不用到500
Tasha: No need to reach 500
Alice:那你多少
Alice: Then how much do you need?
Tasha: 满20 哈哈哈
Tasha: Over 20, hahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈满20满20
Jake: Hahaha over 20, over 20
Alice:来最后一个
Alice: Come on, the last one
Alice:随便拿几个券
Alice: Just grab a few coupons
Tasha: 我不确定满多少
Tasha: I'm not sure how much
Tasha: 我看一下
Tasha: Let me check
Alice: 你先你先把那个满500的那个10块钱用了
Alice: First, use the 10 yuan off 500 one
Jake: 凑到了500
Jake: We hit 500
Tasha: 满49和满29哎
Tasha: Over 49 and over 29, hey
Jake: 先用49的
Jake: Use the 49 one first
Tasha: 满29的水果券
Tasha: The 29 fruit coupon
Jake: 先用49的
Jake: Use the 49 one first
Tasha: 这个是用的什么券
Tasha: Which coupon did you use?
Shure:  哎差不多差不多
Shure: Hey, close enough, close enough
Shure:  无所谓无所谓
Shure: It doesn't matter, it doesn't matter
Tasha: 这是水果卷
Tasha: This is a fruit coupon
Katrina: 要吗
Katrina: Do you want it?
Jake: 他一天能扫这么多
Jake: He can scan this many in a day
Tasha: 还有一个海鲜券
Tasha: There's still a seafood coupon
Shure:  给杨老板省了不到一新币
Shure: Saved Jake less than one dollar.
Alice:有海鲜吗
Alice: Is there any seafood?
Katrina: 海鲜是不是扫完了
Katrina: Is the seafood all scanned?
Alice:我们买海鲜了吗
Alice: Did we buy any seafood?
Katrina:  没有买海鲜
Katrina: We didn't buy any seafood.
Jake: 一新币很重要的
Jake: One dollar is very important.
Tasha: 那好吧那就扫不完了
Tasha: Alright then, we can't scan everything.
Jake: 一新币可以
Jake: One dollar can...
Lucia: 虾虾虾滑算海鲜吗
Lucia: Do shrimp balls count as seafood?
Shure:  可口可乐能买吗
Shure: Can we buy Coca-Cola?
Jake: 买不了哈哈哈
Jake: Nope, can't buy it, haha.
Tasha: 虾滑算海鲜吗
Tasha: Do shrimp balls count as seafood?
Tasha: 完了那部分被我
Tasha: Oh no, that part got...
Tasha: 们扫掉了
Tasha: ...scanned by us.
Shure:  没事的没事的
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 算了吧
Katrina: Never mind.
Shure:  就这样吧
Shure: Let's leave it at that.
Katrina: 买了1,000块钱
Katrina: We bought things worth 1,000 dollars.
Jake: 1新币能干嘛呢
Jake: What can one dollar do?
Katrina:  省十块也没有
Katrina: Not even saving ten dollars.
Tasha: 好吧那扫吧
Tasha: Alright then, let's scan it.
Katrina:  那就只有这一个券是吗
Katrina: So there's only this coupon, right?
Tasha: 这个是不是扫过了
Tasha: Is this one scanned already?
Alice:我这个扫了吗
Alice: Did I scan this one?
Tasha: 坐公交或许
Tasha: Maybe for taking the bus...
Jake: 坐不了哈哈
Jake: Can't even take the bus, haha.
Katrina:  这两个扫了
Katrina: These two are scanned.
Katrina: 这个我忘了
Katrina: I forgot about this one.
Katrina:  这个午餐肉扫了吗
Katrina: Did we scan this luncheon meat?
Alice:这还没扫
Alice: This one isn't scanned yet.
Jake: 呃得一块七
Jake: Uh, it's one dollar and seventy cents.
Shure:  哎呀呀呀
Shure: Oh no, no, no.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  你又加了一个
Shure: You added another one.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  那什么你刚才不小心加了一个
Shure: Well, you accidentally added another one just now.
Katrina:  那个但是他是这个吗
Katrina: But is it this one?
Tasha: 这个吗
Tasha: This one?
Katrina:  他们那边公交路上
Katrina: They were on the bus route.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Jake: 不知道耶
Jake: I don't know.
Katrina:  这没扫吧
Katrina: This hasn't been scanned, right?
Jake: 可能
Jake: Maybe.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one.
Jake: 国内也是两块钱
Jake: It's two yuan back home too.
Katrina: 这没扫没扫
Katrina: This hasn't been scanned, hasn't been scanned.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Jake: 没错没错
Jake: That's right, that's right.
Jake: 这边也是两
Jake: It's two here too.
Jake: 那边也两块钱
Jake: And two yuan over there.
Jake: 国内刷支付宝只要这
Jake: Using Alipay in China only costs this much.
Alice: 感觉不能再装了
Alice: Feels like we can't fit anymore.
Alice:这个装巨多饮料
Alice: This fits a ton of drinks.
Tasha: 这个扫过了是吧
Tasha: This one has been scanned, right?
Alice: 扫过了这都是扫过的
Alice: It's all been scanned.
Katrina:  桌上都是扫过的
Katrina: Everything on the table has been scanned.
Shure:  哎呦sorry sorry
Shure: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Shure:  不好意思
Shure: My bad.
Alice: 这个真的还能装沉的吗
Alice: Can it still hold more?
Tasha: 小瓶子放进去OK
Tasha: Small bottles are fine.
Alice: 主要是这个重量
Alice: It's mainly the weight.
Lucia: 这里面好像饮料比较多
Lucia: Seems like there are more drinks in here.
Tasha: 别别别压他了别压他了
Tasha: Don't press him down anymore.
Tasha: 好了就这样吧
Tasha: Alright, just leave it like this.
Tasha: 能扎上吗
Tasha: Can you tie it up?
Jake: 我来扎我来扎
Jake: Let me tie it.
Lucia: 这个这把这个拿起来
Lucia: Take this one up.
Lucia: 然后把这个放在这扎
Lucia: Then place this here and tie it.
Lucia: 可能好扎一些
Lucia: It might be easier.
Jake: 哎呦进不去
Jake: Oh, it won't go in.
Shure:  妈呀这个一会
Shure: Oh man, this is...
Lucia: 这个好重
Lucia: This is heavy.
Katrina: 这水自带的吧
Katrina: Did this water come with it?
Jake: 分两袋吧
Jake: Let's split it into two bags.
Tasha: 分两车吧
Tasha: Let's split it into two cars.
Jake: 再来辆车
Jake: Let's get another cart.
Jake: 我来开车
Jake: I'll drive.
Tasha: 你去吧
Tasha: You go ahead.
Jake: 我去开车
Jake: I'll go get the car.
Lucia: 这个这个袋子有点太重了
Lucia: This bag is a bit too heavy.
Lucia: 一个可能撑不住
Lucia: One person might not be able to hold it.
Tasha: 我感觉应该分散一点吧
Tasha: I think we should spread it out a bit.
Shure: 这撑不住的
Shure: This can't hold up.
Shure:  这个太太那什么了
Shure: This is too... too much.
Lucia: 就是得抱着
Lucia: We have to hold it.
Lucia: 拿两瓶饮料重要出来
Lucia: Take out two bottles of drinks.
Tasha: 要不把瓶子重新分散吧
Tasha: How about we redistribute the bottles?
Lucia: 然后放到这里面可以吗
Lucia: And then put them in here, is that okay?
Lucia: 这个够重这重吗
Lucia: Is this heavy enough now?
Alice:这个倒是不重
Alice: This isn't heavy.
Shure:  不要把一个鸡蛋装在同一个篮子里哦
Shure: Don't put all your eggs in one basket.
Katrina:  sorry放多个篮子了
Katrina: Sorry, I put them in multiple baskets.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: That's fine.
Tasha: 拿一些这种轻的东西放在这个袋子里
Tasha: Put some light stuff in this bag.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Katrina: 这蓝莓好大呀
Katrina: These blueberries are huge!
Alice:盐火锅底料
Alice: Salt hotpot base.
Jake: 车到了
Jake: The car has arrived.
Lucia: 要要不要再拿瓶饮料出来
Lucia: Should we take another bottle of drink out?
Lucia: 那个这个
Lucia: That one, this one.
Lucia: 这个现在重吗
Lucia: Is this heavy now?
Alice: 这个不重
Alice: This isn't heavy.
Lucia: 我们要是还有别的那还得有别的袋子
Lucia: If we have more stuff, we'll need another bag.
Lucia: 那这个就放这吧
Lucia: Let's just put this here.
Katrina:  他没有布袋子吗
Katrina: Don't they have cloth bags?
Katrina:  只有这种袋子
Katrina: They only have these kinds of bags.
Tasha: 能不能租个推车回去
Tasha: Can we rent a cart to take back?
Lucia: 谢谢会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Thanks, won't it be a bit heavy?
Tasha: 你不会在思考这个可行性吧
Tasha: Are you considering the feasibility?
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha: 不可以
Tasha: It's not possible.
Jake: 真的吗问问
Jake: Really? Ask around.
Jake: 哎呦sorry不好意思不好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry, my bad, my bad.
Katrina: OK 啦这水不是的吧
Katrina: Okay, this water isn't for that, right?
Lucia: 这都是一些怕压的东西
Lucia: These are all things that can't be squashed.
Tasha: 是我的
Tasha: It's mine.
Shure:  现在咱把他们放到最上面吧
Shure: Let's put them on top now.
Lucia: 这个这个还行估计这个先放这里边
Lucia: This is okay, let's put this here first.
Lucia: 像草莓鸡蛋这种这种
Lucia: Like strawberries and eggs, these kinds of things.
Alice: 这个可以放这个
Alice: You can put this here.
Lucia: 哎这俩是一块的
Lucia: Hey, these two go together.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Alice:对这俩是一块
Alice: Yeah, these two go together.
Alice:这是送的
Alice: This one is a freebie.
Jake: 他这不行
Jake: This one doesn't work.
Tasha: 有车吗
Tasha: Do we have a car?
Tasha: 你摄像头呢
Tasha: Where's your camera?
Shure:  有吧
Shure: Got it.
Jake: 呃换一个
Jake: Uh, let's change it.
Jake: 这个没电了
Jake: This one's out of battery.
Jake: 头掉了
Jake: The head fell off.
Katrina:  付钱喽
Katrina: Time to pay up.
Shure:  付钱喽
Shure: Time to pay up.
Jake: 送的呀
Jake: It's free!
Alice:付钱喽
Alice: Time to pay up.
Jake: 要买
Jake: You have to buy it.
Tasha: 9块钱要买厨房湿巾吗
Tasha: Do you want to buy kitchen wipes for 9 bucks?
Shure:  来拿着
Shure: Here, take it.
Katrina:  来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Tasha: 因为不是吃火锅吗
Tasha: Because we’re having hot pot, right?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  拿着
Shure: Here, take it.
Jake: 行
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 9块钱好像
Tasha: 9 bucks, I think.
Tasha: 啊9.9
Tasha: Oh, 9.9.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yep.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Alice:搁这里面
Alice: Put it in here.
Tasha: 我真的还有这么多钱吗
Tasha: Do I really have this much money?
Shure:  我相信你是个大富婆
Shure: I believe you’re a rich lady.
Tasha: 你信错了
Tasha: You’re mistaken.
Lucia: 这个这个能放到这吗
Lucia: Can this go here?
Katrina: 拿着
Katrina: Here, take it.
Shure:  这个
Shure: This one.
Shure:  鸡蛋放这先
Shure: Put the eggs here for now.
Lucia: 先这样吧
Lucia: Let’s leave it like this for now.
Lucia: 然后我们一会可以再看怎么样
Lucia: Then we can check it again later.
Lucia: 整理一下好
Lucia: Let's tidy up a bit.
Shure:  我天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
Lucia: 这还有有包葱
Lucia: There's a bag of scallions here.
Jake: 哼
Jake: Hmph.
Tasha:这结了吗
Tasha: Is this done?
Lucia: 这是蒜
Lucia: This is garlic.
Alice: 这不是葱吗
Alice: Isn't this scallions?
Lucia: 这不是大蒜苗吗
Lucia: Aren't these garlic sprouts?
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: Oh no.
Alice:一样的一样的
Alice: It's the same, the same.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: It doesn't matter.
Shure:  谁不是谁把葱
Shure: Who didn't bring the scallions?
Shure:  哎呀哈哈
Shure: Oh, haha.
Lucia: 再买一个吧
Lucia: Let's buy another one.
Tasha: 可以可以买
Tasha: Yeah, we can buy it.
Lucia: 啊不是我觉得他是葱
Lucia: I thought it was scallions.
Lucia: 他是葱同志们要不要看一眼
Lucia: It's scallions, guys, wanna take a look?
Tasha: 蒜苗就是蒜苗
Tasha: Garlic sprouts are garlic sprouts.
Shure:  蒜苗就是蒜苗
Shure: Garlic sprouts are garlic sprouts.
Tasha: 这这是蒜苗呀
Tasha: These are garlic sprouts.
Lucia: 这是蒜苗吗
Lucia: Are these garlic sprouts?
Alice:是是蒜苗
Alice: Yes, they are garlic sprouts.
是蒜这是一个叠被子
Alice: These are garlic sprouts.
Shure:  完全不是一个味
Shure: Totally different taste.
Tasha: 才买个葱
Tasha: Just buy some scallions.
Katrina: 啊好的
Katrina: Oh, okay.
Alice: 无所谓把它当葱用吧
Alice: Doesn't matter, use them as scallions.
Alice:也可以
Alice: It's fine.
Shure:  咱俩完全不是一个味啊
Shure: We have totally different tastes.
Tasha: 不是一个味啊
Tasha: Different taste, indeed.
Shure:  蒜苗是蒜的味
Shure: Garlic sprouts taste like garlic.
Lucia: 我刚才拿起来突然一看
Lucia: I just picked it up and suddenly realized...
Lucia: 这是到底是什么东西
Lucia: What exactly is this?
Tasha: 再买个葱吗
Tasha: Should we buy more scallions?
Shure:  那张那张账单在谁那呢
Shure: Who has the receipt?
Jake: 可以啊
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  就两个呀
Katrina: Just two, right?
Shure:  还有一张账单啊
Shure: There's another receipt.
Katrina:  第一个没打是不是
Katrina: The first one wasn't scanned, right?
Tasha: 第一个打了
Tasha: The first one was scanned.
Tasha: 谁拿着呢
Tasha: Who's holding it?
Jake: 我我没拿呀
Jake: I didn't take it.
Jake: 我可能没拿吧
Jake: I might not have taken it.
Tasha: 我没拿呀
Tasha: I didn't take it.
Jake: 我应该没拿
Jake: I probably didn't take it.
Tasha: 我应该没拿呀
Tasha: I probably didn't take it.
Jake: 那可能就是拿了吧
Jake: Then maybe it was taken.
Alice: 这不两条吗
Alice: Aren't there two of them?
Tasha: 葱要不要再买一个
Tasha: Should we buy another scallion?
Jake: 两条吗我去
Jake: Two of them? Oh my.
Tasha:葱我去拿吧
Tasha: I'll go get the scallion.
Shure: 本来就两条
Shure: There were originally two.
Jake: 应该连起来
Jake: They should be connected.
Alice:哎哎哎去那边葱
Alice: Hey, hey, hey, go over there for the scallions.
Jake: 订一下
Jake: Place an order.
Alice:有机葱比较贵
Alice: Organic scallions are more expensive.
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my.
Tasha: 不用替他省钱
Tasha: No need to save money for him.
Alice: 啊但我们后面预算不够怎么办啊
Alice: But what if we don't have enough budget later?
Tasha: 说如果预算够的话还能去那个玩了
Tasha: If the budget is enough, we can still go play there.
Alice:这也太多了
Alice: This is too much.
Jake: 去贴门禁
Jake: Go stick the access card.
Tasha: 这也太大了
Tasha: This is too big.
Alice:啊好烫啊
Alice: Ah, it's so hot.
Tasha: 我这也好烫
Tasha: It's so hot here too.
Alice:其实3个葱也不多
Alice: Actually, three scallions aren't too much.
Jake: 那不多
Jake: That's not too much.
Lucia: 这个葱11块8 我觉得
Lucia: This scallion costs 11.8 yuan, I think.
Alice: 这是一斤啊
Alice: Is that per catty?
Tasha: 有没有葱姜蒜组合呀
Tasha: Is there a scallion-ginger-garlic combo?
Tasha: 葱姜蒜组合在哪里啊
Tasha: Where's the scallion-ginger-garlic combo?
Alice: 很小
Alice: It's very small.
Tasha: 要不这个吧
Tasha: How about this one?
Alice:这个够用吗
Alice: Is this enough?
Tasha: 够用了呀
Tasha: It's enough.
Alice:多少钱啊
Alice: How much is it?
Tasha: 两块8 嗯
Tasha: 2.8 yuan, hmm.
Alice:拿两个吧
Alice: Take two then.
Tasha: 那我想要这个好看的
Tasha: Then I want this nice-looking one.
Tasha: 我还想要一个绿的
Tasha: I also want a green one.
Tasha: 那就拿这两个吧
Tasha: Then let's take these two.
Alice:小米辣我们有吗
Alice: Do we have small chili peppers?
Tasha: 呃要单独的小米辣吗
Tasha: Uh, do you want separate chili peppers?
Alice:啊有有都行
Alice: Ah, sure, anything is fine.
Tasha: 有不是火锅底料吗
Tasha: Isn't there already hot pot base?
Tasha: 嗯买过了
Tasha: Yeah, I already bought it.
Alice: 麻酱
Alice: Sesame paste.
Alice:呃不对就是那个底料里面会有
Alice: Uh, no, it should be in the base.
Alice: 如果没有人提话说明没有人爱吃
Alice: If no one mentioned it, it means no one likes it.
Alice:好烫啊烫的我
Alice: It's so hot, it's burning me.
Alice:结一下吧
Alice: Let's settle the bill.
Alice:结吧结吧
Alice: 这怎么拿回去啊
Alice: How are we going to take this back?
Tasha: 他是怎么支付的
Tasha: How did he pay?
Tasha: 呀我就想知道
Tasha: Yeah, I just want to know.
Alice:直接开始结账
Alice: Just start checking out.
Katrina:  你的仓库star还没有老乡鸡多
Katrina: Your warehouse star isn't as popular as Laoxiangji.
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 我们最后一天会去哪里玩啊
Tasha: Where are we going to play on our last day?
Tasha:不是说 如果还有经费会去环球影城玩吗
Tasha: Didn't you say if we have budget left, we would go to Universal Studios?
Tasha: 但是如果没有经费的话可能就不了吧
Tasha: But if there's no budget, then we might not go.
Tasha: 给老板
Tasha: Give it to the boss.
Tasha: 我帮你贴上吗
Tasha: Should I stick it on for you?
Jake: 好啊哈哈哈
Jake: Sure, haha.
Jake: 你就你就
Jake: Just do it.
Jake: 你就欠这一刀
Jake: You just owe this one cut.
Jake: 手带现在这个长度很好
Jake: The length of the strap is good now.
Jake: 就这样
Jake: Just like this.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Shure:  go
Shure: Go.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Tasha: 那芋头还有蛋挞皮
Tasha: Then there's the taro and the tart crusts.
Tasha: 还有刚刚说的薄荷
Tasha: And the mint we just mentioned.
Jake: 这车能推到哪啊
Jake: Where can we push this cart to?
Tasha: 还有你们那个好像还有两个材料
Tasha: And you guys seem to have two more ingredients.
Shure: 门口
Shure: To the entrance.
Jake: 门口
Jake: Entrance.
Jake: 哪个门口外边
Jake: Which entrance, outside?
Tasha: 就从网上买的
Tasha: Just bought it online.
Alice:什么美文纸
Alice: What beautiful paper?
Katrina:  嗯那偏文具类的我上网买
Katrina: Hmm, for stationery stuff, I buy it online.
Katrina:  嗯或者是我看看外送有没有
Katrina: Hmm, or I'll see if there's a delivery option.
Katrina: 因为我们在设计地球的
Katrina: Because we're designing the Earth...
Katrina: 那个海报啊什么都是肯定上网买的啊
Katrina: The posters and stuff are definitely bought online.
Katrina:  啊什么东西上网买
Katrina: What things are bought online?
Katrina: 感觉会漂亮一点
Katrina: It feels like they'd look nicer.
Tasha: 肯定也会在网上买的吧
Tasha: You'll probably buy it online too, right?
Tasha: 我觉得啊
Tasha: I think so.
Tasha: 海报什么东西
Tasha: Posters and stuff.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Oh...
Tasha:这个车不能推到商场门口吗
Tasha: Can't we push this cart to the mall entrance?
Alice:我的天呐啊
Alice: Oh my god!
Jake: 能租车
Jake: You can rent a car.
Lucia: 这叫我们怎么拿出去啊
Lucia: How are we supposed to carry this out?
Tasha: 来我来替您背书包
Tasha: Here, let me carry your backpack for you.
Shure:  杨老板先把车打上吧
Shure: Jake, why don’t you start the car first?
Jake: 好的
Lucia: 这每感觉每个袋子都挺重的
Lucia: 咱这能拿出去吗
Jake: 我们就直接打车了
Jake: 不再买点咖啡什么的
Jake: 不了吧
Jake: 现在有点晚了
Tasha: 不用喝了
Jake: 是吧
Katrina:  我们直接去吃饭是吗
Jake: 好的
Tasha: 对吃什么呢
Shure:  你们拎着这么多东西
Alice: 这地能有放的吗
Shure:  东西
Jake: 确实啊
Shure: 肯定得回趟家
Lucia: 拿这么多东西去吃饭有点
Shure:  要不就吃饭
Tasha: 要不就点外卖吧
Jake: 行回去点外卖吧
Jake: Alright, let's order some takeout when we get back.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Sound good?
Lucia: 都可以一起出去也可以
Lucia: We could all go out together too.
Jake: 在这是就是有冻的东西对吧
Jake: Here, there are frozen items, right?
Shure:  是吧而且还有要要冻的东西
Shure: Yeah, and there are things that need to be frozen.
Jake: 是吧是有冷冻的
Jake: Yeah, there are frozen items.
Jake: 冷冻的东西
Jake: Frozen items.
Shure:  然后大家看一眼那个哪些是冷冻
Shure: Everyone, take a look at what's frozen.
Shure:  哪些是冷藏
Shure: And what's refrigerated.
Katrina:  放一会吧
Katrina: Let it sit for a while.
Shure:  比如说那毛肚什么的
Shure: Like the tripe and stuff.
Shure:  他就是说让0-4度
Shure: He said to keep it at 0-4 degrees.
Tasha: 你要放下来吗
Tasha: Do you want to put it down?
Jake: 啊再来一辆车你要不
Jake: Ah, do you want another cart?
Shure:  他只能到这儿了
Shure: It can only go this far.
Tasha: 他只能到这儿了
Tasha: It can only go this far.
Shure:  爸爸只能送你到这儿了
Shure: Dad can only take you this far.
Shure:  未来的路要靠你自己了
Shure: The rest of the journey is up to you.
Lucia: 妈耶
Lucia: Oh my.
Shure:  听到了吗
Shure: Did you hear that?
Alice:有点沉这个给我吧
Alice: This is a bit heavy, let me take it.
Katrina:  这样我们的冰箱就满了
Katrina: This way, our fridge is full.
Lucia: 冰箱能不能放下呀
Lucia: Can the fridge hold everything?
Shure:  你不要把它喝凉了
Shure: Don't let it get too cold.
Shure:  哈哈哈全喝光
Shure: Hahaha, drink it all up.
Jake: 回头
Jake: Turn around.
Katrina: 草莓也全吃了
Katrina: Eat all the strawberries too.
Jake: 就是这个数据比较重要
Jake: This data is quite important.
Jake: 就是回头你们收拾的时候
Jake: When you guys organize it later,
Jake: 会和超市
Jake: it will help with the supermarket.
Jake: 你们的一些行为建立一些联系
Jake: Your actions will establish some connections.
Jake: 就是比方说你把这东西放到冰箱
Jake: For example, you put this item in the fridge,
Jake: 然后他只能找回到你在哪找到的那个
Jake: and then they can trace back to where you found it.
Lucia: 哦那就跟亚马逊那个无人采购超市
Lucia: Oh, it's like Amazon's cashier-less stores.
Lucia: 一样的那种感觉
Lucia: That kind of feeling.
Jake: 对对对溯源
Jake: Yes, yes, traceability.
Katrina: 溯源啦
Katrina: Traceability, yeah.
Jake: 对就是溯源这种rechieve
Jake: Yes, it's traceability, this kind of retrieve.
Jake: 特厉害你去不
Jake: It's very impressive, are you going?
Shure:  你们上链的吗
Shure: Are you guys on the blockchain?
Shure:  呵呵
Shure: Hehe.
Katrina:  当心哦
Katrina: Be careful.
Katrina:  谢谢阿莫总
Katrina: Thank you, Amo.
Lucia: 阿莫总开了好几个那种
Lucia: Amos opened several of those
Lucia: 那种超市
Lucia: those supermarkets
Lucia: 就是你出门不用结账
Lucia: where you don't need to checkout
Lucia: 他知道你买了什么
Lucia: It knows what you bought
Lucia: 然后自动在你的账户里付款
Lucia: and it automatically charges your account
Lucia: 就是他根据你的重量
Lucia: based on the weight
Lucia: 好像就是你放进去然后东西多重
Lucia: Like you put it in and it calculates the weight
Lucia: 对他会精确到多少多少毫克
Lucia: Yeah, it can be precise to a few milligrams
Lucia: 然后呢他就会自动把这钱扣走
Lucia: Then it automatically deducts the money
Lucia: 是超市里
Lucia: In the supermarket
Lucia: 就跟我们一样
Lucia: just like us
Jake:那我要稍微哎
Jake: Then I need to, hey
Lucia: 就是它有很多摄像头
Lucia: There are many cameras
Lucia: 就是能看到你拿了什么
Lucia: that can see what you take
Lucia: 他监测你有没有在货架上拿东西
Lucia: They monitor if you take something from the shelves
Lucia: 包括你进出的时候的各种数据
Lucia: including various data when you enter and exit
Lucia: 反正很神奇的一个东西
Lucia: It's quite a magical thing
Lucia: 不过就是偶尔有算错的可能性
Lucia: But there's a chance of miscalculation sometimes
Lucia: 呵呵不过有时候是会算错的
Lucia: Hehe, but sometimes it does miscalculate
Jake: 他还有6分钟到
Jake: He'll be here in 6 minutes
Alice:开始往下走吧
Alice: Let's start going down
Jake: 往上走好像是
Jake: It seems like we should go up
Jake:这是往上走对吧
Jake: We're going up, right?
Katrina:  往下吧
Katrina: Let's go down
Alice:我们不是二楼吗
Alice: Aren't we on the second floor?
Alice:我们是这样上来的呀
Alice: We came up this way
Jake:哦这么回事啊
Jake: Oh, I see
Alice: 一进门一进门不是有个升的电梯
Alice: As soon as you enter, there's an elevator that goes up
Jake: 有道理
Jake: Makes sense
Jake: 因为这地方太像地下了
Jake: Because this place feels like a basement
Alice: 有点阴森有点不热闹
Alice: It's a bit eerie and not lively
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go
Alice:有点
Alice: A bit
Katrina:  这我来吧
Katrina: Let me do it
Katrina: 因为我有一个鸡蛋
Katrina: Because I have an egg
Alice: 没事这个不沉
Alice: It's okay, it's not heavy
Katrina:  你看
Katrina: Look
Katrina:  没事我就一点点都没
Katrina: It's okay, I barely have anything
Tasha: 你你一个人拎两个
Tasha: You carry two by yourself
Katrina: 就主要是那个酒比较多的那个
Katrina: Mainly because that one has a lot of wine
Jake: 你你你这么厉害吗
Jake: You, you, you are this amazing?
Alice: 而且饮料多的比较沉
Alice: Also, the drinks are heavier.
Alice: 你再一人掂一掂
Alice: You should try lifting them one by one.
Jake: 这才对嘛
Jake: This is right.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  您是
Shure: Are you...
Katrina: 没事你你
Katrina: It's okay, you, you...
Katrina: 真的可以这样利用老板吗
Katrina: Can you really use the boss like this?
Shure:  天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake:这样比较平衡
Jake: This way is more balanced.
Shure:  这样比较这厨房湿巾一定很沉吧
Shure: This way, the kitchen wipes must be very heavy.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这这鸡蛋也很沉吧
Tasha: Hahaha, these eggs are also very heavy, right?
Lucia: 哈哈这鸡蛋很宝贵
Lucia: Haha, these eggs are precious.
Shure:  对没事
Shure: Yes, it's okay.
Katrina:  我需要专人护送
Katrina: I need a personal escort.
Shure:  我只送到你们到门口
Shure: I'll only escort you to the door.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Fine.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我这线是掉了吗
Jake: Did my cable fall off?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 老板
Tasha: Boss.
Tasha: 老板拎着最多的东西
Tasha: The boss is carrying the most stuff.
Lucia: 真的真的
Lucia: Really, really.
Lucia: 要不要帮你安上
Lucia: Do you need help with it?
Jake:好啊好啊
Jake: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Hold on a sec.
Lucia: 你别走
Lucia: Don't go.
Jake: OK了开始开动
Jake: Okay, let's start.
Katrina: connected
Katrina: Connected.
小薇Shure:  这是老板吗
Tasha and Shure: Is this the boss?
Shure:  这是老板吗
Shure: Is this the boss?
Shure:  我们是被一个AI领导的一群人类
Shure: Are we being led by an AI?
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Tasha: 呃重吗我跟你一起拎
Tasha: Uh, is it heavy? I'll carry it with you.
Alice:不用不用这个就一个兜啊
Alice: No need, no need, it's just one bag.
Jake: 就我我头上的和我眼前的
Jake: Just the one on my head and the one in front of me.
Shure: 那个鸡蛋保护起来一定很累
Shure: Protecting those eggs must be exhausting.
Jake: 就是我的接收设备
Jake: It's my receiving equipment.
Katrina: 不行你没有这个资格
Katrina: No, you don't have the qualification.
Jake: 我全靠他来支撑我
Jake: I rely entirely on it to support me.
Jake: 哈哈哈一些行为
Jake: Hahaha, some behaviors
Lucia: 这个故事开始向恐怖片方向发展了
Lucia: This story is starting to turn into a horror movie
Shure:  但
Shure: But
Katrina:  蛋蛋
Katrina: Egg, egg
Tasha: 这颗葱拐到你的脚了
Tasha: This onion rolled onto your foot
Tasha: 我帮你拿着
Tasha: Let me hold it for you
Shure:  你要把鼻也夹进去
Shure: You need to pinch your nose too
Jake:啊会吗谢谢
Jake: Ah, really? Thanks
Katrina: 所以他们要
Katrina: So they need to
Jake: 所以很重要
Jake: So it's important
Katrina: 所以你们最后买葱了吗
Katrina: So did you guys end up buying the onion?
Jake: 哈哈哈所以呢
Jake: Hahaha, so?
Jake:哈哈哈critical
Jake: Hahaha, critical
Alice:买了买了
Alice: We bought it, we bought it
Alice:不是这还是蒜苗
Alice: No, this is still garlic sprouts
Alice:我们的葱在那个篮里面呢
Alice: Our onion is in that basket
Tasha: 买了一个葱姜蒜组合
Tasha: We bought an onion, ginger, and garlic combo
Shure:  发明这个的人真是天才
Shure: The person who invented this is a genius
Jake: 我觉得每人带根线是有点酷啊
Jake: I think everyone carrying a wire is kinda cool
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly
Jake:你这么一眼看过去
Jake: When you take a look around
Alice:尤其我们这样走在一起
Alice: Especially when we walk together like this
Shure: 一会我回程的路上要地铁
Shure: Later, on my way back, I'll take the subway
Alice:感觉像一个什么组织
Alice: Feels like some kind of organization
Tasha: 有点像一个神秘组织
Tasha: Feels like some secret organization
Shure: 这个数据要录下来吗
Shure: Should we record this data?
Jake: 可以录
Jake: We can record it
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK
Tasha: 尤其这个眼镜还发光的感觉
Tasha: Especially these glowing glasses
Katrina: 但他地铁要差不多两个小时
Katrina: But his subway ride takes almost two hours
Jake:你地铁你地铁
Jake: Your subway, your subway
Tasha: 大家都带同一款
Tasha: Everyone's wearing the same style
Jake: 进个进一下出一下得了
Jake: Just get in and out quickly
Jake: 你就进去吧
Jake: Just get in
Jake: 进去然后就关掉
Jake: Get in and then turn it off
Jake: 然后主要是你看你答辩
Jake: The main thing is to see your defense
Jake:哈哈哈你答辩
Jake: Hahaha, your defense
Shure:  方便吗方便哎
Shure: Is it convenient? Convenient, yeah
Jake:方便
Jake: Convenient
Shure:  说我在进行一个奇怪的项目
Shure: I'll say I'm working on a strange project
Jake: 对你问Andy想不想进数据集
Jake: Right, you ask Andy if he wants to be in the dataset.
Jake: 想不想被人研究研究
Jake: Does he want to be studied?
Tasha: 美修类喔 不知道唉
Tasha: Um, not sure about that.
Lucia: 我们往哪走啊
Lucia: Where are we going?
Lucia: 是这边吗
Lucia: Is it this way?
Alice: 都可以出去
Alice: We can go out from here.
Tasha: 这边是我们刚刚
Tasha: This is where we just...
Tasha: 最近的那个
Tasha: The closest one...
Katrina:  嗯不不不
Katrina: Uh, no no no.
Alice:这个门这个门
Alice: This door, this door.
Alice:都一样
Alice: It's all the same.
Lucia: yes yes
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Jake: 这是探路去了
Jake: They went to explore.
Shure:  要不我送你们到这我就先溜了
Shure: How about I drop you off here and then I'll head out?
Shure:  走吧再见
Shure: Let's go, see you.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Jake: 哎我想挠头我靠
Jake: Ah, I want to scratch my head, damn.
Jake: 拜拜明天见
Jake: Bye, see you tomorrow.
Jake: 喂你好
Jake: Hello?
Shure:  明天见今晚不要想我哦
Shure: See you tomorrow, don't think of me tonight.
Shure: 希望不要想我哦
Shure: Hopefully, you won't think of me.
Katrina: 希望你答辩顺利哦
Katrina: Hope your defense goes well.
Katrina:  对你就到这了
Katrina: Yep, you stop here.
Shure:  对我就到这了
Shure: Yep, I'll stop here.
Shure:  呃所以你不能只拎一包湿巾
Shure: Uh, so you can't just carry one pack of wipes.
Jake: 呃呃我找找你吧
Jake: Uh, uh, I'll come find you.
Jake: 我按照定位找你吧
Jake: I'll follow the location to find you.
Jake: 你到了对吧
Jake: You arrived, right?
Shure:  所以你不能只拎一包湿巾了
Shure: So, you can't just carry one pack of wipes.
Shure:  拜拜
Shure: Bye.
Jake: 哎哎拜拜拜拜
Jake: Ah, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Tasha: 无语哈哈哈
Tasha: Speechless, hahaha.
Alice: 我们这能放下吗
Alice: Can we fit it here?
Lucia: 同想问
Lucia: I was wondering the same.
Alice:可以吧
Alice: Should be fine.
Katrina: 放后备箱
Katrina: Put it in the trunk.
Jake: 你看你看是在
Jake: Look, look, it's...
Alice: 嗯是这个门出去
Alice: Yeah, it's this door to go out.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Alice: 我们刚刚下车的地
Alice: The place where we just got off
Katrina:  我们俩一起
Katrina: The two of us together
Jake: 那你帮我导个航
Jake: Can you navigate for me?
Jake: 好谢谢你
Jake: Okay, thank you
Katrina:  哎我好害怕这人
Katrina: Oh, I'm really scared of this person
Jake: 谢谢您
Jake: Thank you
Jake: 哎呦
Jake: Oh dear
Katrina:  哇这一包这么重
Katrina: Wow, this bag is so heavy
Katrina: 他刚刚拎的
Katrina: He just carried it
Lucia: 没有那袋重
Lucia: Not as heavy as that bag
Tasha: 我说真的
Tasha: I'm serious
Katrina:  因为我买了两大瓶哎
Katrina: Because I bought two big bottles
Tasha: 谢谢谢谢
Tasha: Thank you, thank you
Jake: 这个很重要这个很重要这个
Jake: This is very important, very important
Alice:好了不用走了就在这
Alice: Okay, no need to walk, we're here
Katrina:  他能进来吗
Katrina: Can he come in?
Alice: 是呢
Alice: Yes
Jake: 他能进来啊
Jake: He can come in?
Jake: 这么厉害
Jake: That's impressive
Katrina:  我就把这个放下了啊
Katrina: I'll just put this down, okay?
Jake: 今天挺暖和的
Jake: It's quite warm today
Jake: 一点也不冷
Jake: Not cold at all
Katrina:  新加坡一般多少度啊
Katrina: What's the usual temperature in Singapore?
Jake: 呃 23-31每天
Jake: Uh, 23-31 degrees every day
Tasha: 这么热
Tasha: So hot
Katrina:  这么热一年四季都是吗
Katrina: So hot, all year round?
Jake: 每天都一样
Jake: Every day is the same
Tasha: 这么热嗯
Tasha: So hot, hmm
Jake: 每天都一样
Jake: Every day is the same
Jake: 是挺闷的
Jake: It's quite muggy
Jake: 但是现在我适应了
Jake: But now I'm used to it
Jake: 我觉得还好
Jake: I think it's okay
Jake: 只要中午不出去都还好
Jake: As long as you don't go out at noon, it's fine
Tasha: 哇你看这个大葱头
Tasha: Wow, look at this big onion
Tasha: 上下两层都是这样子的
Tasha: It's like this on both layers
Jake: 对是不是每天都一样
Jake: Yeah, isn't it the same every day?
Alice:我是不是得
Alice: Should I...
Jake: 赤道2度北纬2度
Jake: 2 degrees north of the equator
Lucia: 真的好热
Lucia: It's really hot
Lucia: 你知不知道
Lucia: Do you know that?
Alice:往那再走一点点
Alice: Move a little further that way.
Katrina: 路边是不是应该进不来吧
Katrina: Shouldn't the roadside be inaccessible?
Tasha: 他不能进来吗
Tasha: Can't he come in?
Jake: 到了吗
Jake: Are we there yet?
Alice:不知道能不能过去
Alice: Not sure if we can get through.
Tasha: 让他打电话问他一下吧
Tasha: Let him call and ask.
Jake: 我这个电话我这欠费了
Jake: My phone's out of credit.
Jake: 打不出去
Jake: Can't make calls.
Jake: 咱们下课里面是啥
Jake: What's inside after our class?
Shure:  是啥呀
Shure: What's inside?
Tasha: 让他进来调个头
Tasha: Let him come in and turn around.
Jake: 他是什么色的
Jake: What color is he in?
Alice:他好像停了
Alice: He seems to have stopped.
Lucia: 棕色
Lucia: Brown.
Alice:别克GL8
Alice: It's a Buick GL8.
Jake: 他是要我们走过去吧
Jake: Does he want us to walk over?
Alice:我们应该往前走一点点吧
Alice: We should probably walk a bit forward.
Tasha: 我都没看到那辆车唉
Tasha: I can't see that car at all.
Jake: 那我们走吧
Jake: Then let's go.
Jake: 走哎
Jake: Let's go, hey.
Jake: 我刚刚拿的是这个吗
Jake: Was I holding this just now?
Tasha: 是
Tasha: Yes.
Jake: 这是地铁吗
Jake: Is this the subway?
Alice: 喂您好
Alice: Hello?
Tasha: 哪哪
Tasha: Where, where?
Jake: 最前面这一条
Jake: The very front one.
Jake: 天上这一条
Jake: The one in the sky.
Lucia: 是的那呃
Lucia: Yes, that one, uh...
Alice:呃暂时还没有
Alice: Uh, not yet, temporarily.
Jake: 1号线哎
Jake: Line 1, hey.
Jake: 是1号线吗
Jake: Is it Line 1?
Katrina: 咱走这出去吧
Katrina: Let's go out this way.
Alice:永和大王
Alice: Yonghe King.
Jake: 奔驰啊是吗呵呵呵
Jake: A Mercedes, huh? Haha.
Jake: 是吧哈哈
Jake: Right? Haha.
Alice: 永和大王门口
Alice: In front of Yonghe King.
Lucia: 永和大王那边
Lucia: Over by Yonghe King.
Tasha: 门口
Tasha: In front.
Alice:是是那个吗
Alice: Is it that one?
Alice: 我靠哎呀
Alice: Oh my god, geez.
Alice:双闪的
Alice: Double flashers.
Katrina: 啥颜色
Katrina: What color?
Alice:看到有双闪
Alice: I see double flashers.
Lucia: 哪有哪有
Lucia: Where? Where?
Alice: 咋是不是那个呀
Alice: Is it that one?
Jake: 啊我看到了
Jake: Ah, I see it.
Jake: 对对对确实
Jake: Yes, yes, definitely.
Alice:我是不是得绕一下
Alice: Should I go around?
Jake: 呃就那边吧
Jake: Uh, just over there.
Jake: 不用绕
Jake: No need to go around.
Alice: 那个那个我们这能出去吧
Alice: That one, that one, can we get out here?
Katrina: 我们去
Katrina: Let's go.
Shure:  啊我现在
Shure: Ah, I'm now...
Tasha: 我先过算了哎哎好吧
Tasha: I'll go first, alright, alright.
Tasha: 抬一下
Tasha: Lift it up a bit.
Alice:好的我们找到了谢谢
Alice: Okay, we found it, thanks.
Lucia: 这个我们是不是可以放后备箱
Lucia: Can we put this in the trunk?
Jake: fa
Lucia: 或者之类的
Lucia: Or something like that?
Alice: 后备箱可以打开吗
Alice: Can we open the trunk?
Tasha: 啊天呐咦
Tasha: Ah, gosh, oh.
Alice:有点小
Alice: It's a bit small.
Katrina: 够还是够
Katrina: It's enough, still enough.
Alice:挤一下吧
Alice: Squeeze it in.
Alice:再来一个
Alice: One more.
Katrina:  鸡蛋我抱着吧
Katrina: I'll hold the eggs.
Katrina:  这不还和鸡蛋放哪了
Katrina: Didn't we put the eggs here?
Jake: 谢谢哎呀哎呦
Jake: Thanks, oh, ouch.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Careful.
Katrina:  哎呦哎呦
Katrina: Ouch, ouch.
Katrina:  疼
Katrina: It hurts.
Jake: 好疼
Jake: So painful.
Alice:还空出来一个位
Alice: There's still a spot left.
Alice:要不然搁前边吧
Alice: Should we put it in front?
Katrina:  放放我身上也行
Katrina: Putting it on me is fine too.
Katrina:  这后面只有两个人
Katrina: There are only two people in the back.
Jake: 就放那边吧
Jake: Just put it over there.
Jake: 放那边可以吧
Jake: Is it okay to put it there?
Jake: 还是放哎呦
Jake: Or still put it... ouch.
Jake: 看一眼
Jake: Take a look.
Jake: 好疼好疼啊
Jake: Ouch, it hurts, it hurts!
Shure:  不行
Shure: No way.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵摸摸头
Jake: Haha, pat my head.
Shure:  OK好OK
Shure: OK, OK.
Jake: 摸摸头
Jake: Pat my head.
Jake: 哎不用不用不用
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 它自动的它自动的它自动的自动的
Jake: It's automatic, it's automatic, it's automatic.
Alice:好的给你的
Alice: Alright, here you go.
Jake: 摁了他就以为我们要干什么
Jake: If you press it, he'll think we are up to something.
Alice:我们俩坐后边吧
Alice: Let's sit in the back.
Tasha: 行啊
Tasha: Sure.
Tasha: 啊怎么还订6座呢
Tasha: Ah, why did we book 6 seats?
Jake: 那应该点几座
Jake: How many should we have booked?
Katrina:  那我坐老板位了
Katrina: I'll sit in the boss's seat then.
Lucia: 如果没有人晕车的话
Lucia: If no one gets car sick.
Alice:来吧baby
Alice: Come on, baby.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Tasha: 疼疼疼
Tasha: It hurts, it hurts.
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my!
Tasha: 好疼
Tasha: It really hurts.
Lucia: 哎这个能往后一点吗
Lucia: Hey, can this move back a bit?
Lucia: 啊不我是说这个
Lucia: Ah no, I mean this.
Alice:现在还要录吗
Alice: Do we still need to record now?
Jake: 这个关了吧不
Jake: Let's turn this off, no?
Jake: 不用录了
Jake: No need to record.
Tasha: 呃现在就关了
Tasha: Uh, turn it off now.
Jake: 现在关了
Jake: Turn it off now.
Jake: 可以这一段可以
Jake: This part is good, this part is good.
Jake: 这一段主要没有go Pro
Jake: This part mainly doesn't have GoPro.